le massacre de Chatou est l'un des
derniers massacres de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale il a eu lieu le 25 août 1944
même jour que la libération de Paris le
château de la pièce d'eau est situé à
Chatou et le 17 août les Forces
Françaises de l'Intérieur FFI
parviennent à le récupérer des mains de
l'occupant les résistants français
décident alors de laisser en captivité
une quarantaine de soldats allemands
dans le garage de la propriété mais ils
sont rapidement dénoncés par des
collaborateurs français auprès des
Allemands rescapés le 24 août les
Français fétait l'arrivée de la 2e
division blindée de Charles de Gaulle
pendant ce temps les Allemands prenaient
soin de miner tous les ponts de l'Ouest
parisien pour empêcher la libération de
Paris et le vendredi 25 août les unités
allemandes prennent violemment d'assaut
le château de la pièce d'eau ils
oppressent les résistants pour récupérer
leurs prisonniers le commandant Auguste
torset est abattu et les FFI sont fait
prisonniers puis massacrés au total 27
hommes sont morts et la ville de Chatou
a décidé d'ériger un monument à leur
hommage le 11 juin 1950